what's up everybody
it's Warren and a very happy New Year to
all of you I wanted to start this new
year off with a bang which is why I'm
really excited about today's video to
present to you this theory that I've
wanted to talk about for a very long
time now I did a video about four months
ago on a theory talking about how
Galactus is the Power Stone and how they
could introduce him in phase four in the
MCU I got a lot of positive responses
from it but I also got a lot of
questions regarding who exactly are
trapped inside of the other Infinity
stones so here's my video on how the
Phoenix force is the mind stone or how
the Phoenix force is trapped inside of
the mine stone and how they can
introduce the Phoenix force and the
x-men in phase four of the MCU I will
also be announcing the winner of my
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway at the end of
this video so be sure to stick around
till the end to see who won so on the
surface this theory is pretty simple
it's what I stated the Phoenix force is
trapped inside of the mine stone and
that's where the mine stone gets its
power from but of course in order to
figure out when and how the Phoenix
force got trapped inside of the mine
stone we have to dig a lot deeper and in
order to answer this question on how the
Phoenix force can be trapped inside of
the mine stone you have to have a little
bit of an understanding of what exactly
the Infinity stones are in the MCU but
more specifically what exactly the
collector says about the Infinity stones
and guardians of the galaxy and what
Odin says about the Infinity stones in
Thor the dark world and Thor the dark
world when Odin is explaining the
Infinity stones to Thor he describes
them as relics that predate the universe
with me are relics that predate the
universe itself what lies within her
appears to be one of them
nine realms and not eternal headed or
they would have a does and then of
course in guardians of the galaxy the
collector went into even more detail
about what exactly the Infinity stones
are and how they came to be creation
itself there were sixteen your attitudes
then loaded into existence and the
remnants of these systems were forged
into concentrated ingots infinity still
so how the collector describes the
Infinity stones in this scene is very
important so before the current universe
that the MCU is in existed there were
six singularities and then the current
universe exploded into existence and the
remnants of these systems were forged
into concentrated ingots and the key
word here is remnants remnants that
existed before the current universe
exploded into existence the definition
of a remnant is a small remaining
quantity of something so what the
collector and what Odin are saying is
that before our universe existed there
were these singularities these systems
these relics that existed before and
when our universe exploded into
existence there were small remaining
pieces of these systems leftover and
then these remnants that were left over
from the previous systems were forged
into Infinity stones so those were how
the current Infinity stones came into
existence now let's talk about how the
Phoenix force came into existence in our
current universe our current universe
exploded into existence from the Big
Bang but the Big Bang actually destroyed
the previous universe just as Galactus
existed in the previous universe as a
person known as Galen the Phoenix force
also existed in the previous universe in
fact the Phoenix force played a huge
part in the recreation of Galen into
Galactus remember the Infinity stones
are remnants of the previous universe if
you go to Marvel's website and you look
up the Phoenix force this is what it
says in its biography born of the void
between states of being the Phoenix
force is a child of the universe in the
dying moments of the previous universe
the force saved all existence from
eternal dead
nation enabling eternity to preserve the
humanoid Galen ensuring his recreation
as Galactus the force was subsequently
reborn from the cosmic fires of the Big
Bang so as you can see in the previous
universe the Phoenix force actually
saved Galen which enabled him to become
Galactus in the current universe and of
course obviously the Phoenix force
existed in a previous universe and now
exists in the current universe
this lines up exactly with what the
collector and what Odin said about the
Infinity stones they said that before
our universe existed there were these
singularities these systems these relics
that existed they existed before our
universe much like the Phoenix force
existed before our universe and then the
current universe exploded into existence
by the big bang banks and 6 elemental
crystals huddling across the virgin
universe these Infinity stones each
controlled an essential aspect of
existence and there were remnants of
these systems left over one of them
being the Phoenix force so I said this
in the previous video but this is where
you have to be aware that the MCU is
different than the comics they obviously
don't just recreate the stories from the
comics they don't follow them to the tee
however they do draw inspiration from
the comics and this is how Marvel could
and quite possibly could have already
retconned the Phoenix force being the
mine stone into the MCU it really
wouldn't be that hard to retcon the
Phoenix force as the mine stone into the
MCU the Infinity stones in the MCU are
essentially pure energy and if you look
in the x-men Phoenix force handbook this
is how it describes the Phoenix force
born of the void between states of being
the Phoenix force is allegedly a nexus
of all the psionic energy that has does
and ever will exist in all realities of
the multiverse in the dying moments of
the previous universe the Big Crunch the
Makran crystal a hyper cubical nexus of
realities was shattered bringing the
entire multiverse to an end however the
Phoenix force saved all of the Dyne
universes inhabitants from eternal
damnation so according to the Phoenix
force handbook the Phoenix force is a
nexus of all the psionic energy that has
and ever will exist in all realities of
the multiverse sounds like that could
easily be an infinity stone also in the
comics the mine stone is actually blue
but in the MCU they made a yellow which
matches the main color of the Phoenix
forces yellow red and orange it's blue
we're blue it's just important okay
trust us here is the main point in the
really big argument for the fact that
the mine stone could be the Phoenix
force we learned and know that the
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver got their
powers from the mine stone but they
didn't just get magical powers from the
stone we learned that the stone actually
awoke powers that they already had that
were lying dormant we learned this from
The Avengers age of Ultron prelude comic
one-shot in this comic it explains
exactly how Quicksilver and the Scarlet
Witch got their powers in the
post-credits scene of Captain America
the Winter Soldier we learned that
Wolfgang von Strucker is in possession
of Loki's scepter then in the comic
one-shot we learned that Strucker has
been doing experiments and tests on
residents of the fictional European city
sokovia hoping to use the scepter to
unlock any inheritant powers that they
may have this is how Quicksilver and the
Scarlet Witch end up getting their
powers from Loki's scepter which we of
course have learned is actually the mine
stone but what we learned from The
Avengers age of Ultron prelude comic is
that the mine stone didn't give the
powers to Quicksilver in The Scarlet
Witch but it actually unlocked powers
that they already had sound familiar
it sounds like the x-gene lying dormant
in a mutant exposure to the mine stone
activated their dormant X genes giving
them mutant powers this explains why all
of the other people that Strucker
experimented on with Loki's scepter
didn't get any powers they simply did
not have the X gene inside of them so
this makes perfect sense that the
Phoenix force is actually trapped inside
of the mine stone and it is actually the
Phoenix force that is giving Quicksilver
and the Scarlet Witch their mutant
powers and this is how Marvel can
introduce the x-men into the MCU by
destroying the mine stone during the
Avengers vs. x-men storyline the Phoenix
force returns to earth the Avengers
anticipate the destruction that the
Phoenix
could bring while Cyclops and the x-men
hope to use the Phoenix force to restart
the mutant population at the end of the
storyline the Phoenix force since a
blast a Phoenix fire across the whole
entire earth this activates latent X
genes inside of people and creates new
mutants around the world obviously this
can't happen in the MCU because mutants
aren't in the MCU yet but the Phoenix
force could be trapped inside of the
mine stone so at the end of Avengers
endgame if they choose to destroy all of
the Infinity stones to keep anybody else
in the future from collecting them all
and using them they could unleash the
Phoenix force by destroying the mine
stone and also Galactus by destroying
the Power Stone
but unleashing the Phoenix force could
activate the latent X genes inside of
mutants therefore bringing mutants into
the MCU this is a perfect and fitting
way to bring mutants into the MCU and I
wouldn't be surprised if Marvel is
already planning this again we know that
Quicksilver and the Scarlet Witch got
their powers from the mine stone and we
know they're mutants even though Marvel
didn't own the rights to use mutants in
the MCU at the time of age of Ultron
they could have anticipated that they
would eventually be able to use them and
now the Disney foxtail is basically done
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios has even commented on when we
can expect the x-men and the Fantastic
Four to enter the MCU and it's not long
from now he said that in the first six
months of 2019 they're going to start
developing stories and Marvel has
literally said that the mind stone
unlocked powers that Quicksilver and the
Scarlet Witch already had there's no
doubt that they're mutants and they were
planning on them entering the MCU at one
point so it makes sense that the Phoenix
force could be trapped inside of the
mine stone and it is what activated the
latent X genes inside of Quicksilver in
The Scarlet Witch and then if the mine
stone gets destroyed it could sent a
Phoenix fire blast across the earth
activating the X genes inside of people
bringing mutants into the MCU so that is
it on how the Phoenix force is trapped
inside of the mine stone and how the
x-men can be brought into the MCU in
phase four let me know what you think
about this theory do you
that the Phoenix force could be inside
of the mine stone and that the
destruction of it could bring mutants
into the MCU let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and congrats
to Darth Adams for being the winner of
the Infinity Gauntlet giveaway send me
an email and the email in my description
and I'll send you your Infinity Gauntlet
for the rest of you don't worry I'm
doing another Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
starting right now so if you would like
to enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
with the notifications turned on like
the video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Applause]
you